c'est non non
bonjour nous allons avoir maintenant un
entretien avec monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing président d sais pas pourquoi
le
président de la république mais
malheureusement il semble que giscard
est à la bourre un peu à la barre un peu
à la bourre mais il devrait pas tarder
parce que je crois bien que j'entends
sont pas
là
[Musique]
pour swarm bonjour mon président bonjour
madame
bonjour mademoiselle bonjour monsieur
je suis venu vous parler de la france
et au passage mon cher pour uzi je veux
remercier pour cet entretien au point du
bois le 15e depuis mon accession à la
présidence de la république en 1962 qu'à
14 7 ans 74e vous êtes élu je m'appelle
pas mourousi chaud ici d'une vieille
famille de cyclistes monde ma grande
taille à l'écouter on vous demande pas
si votre grand mère sud il en cite les
urgences plus crucial enfin j'avais vu
les sondages oui albon alors que
maintenant mais c'est président les
vacances sont terminées poil au nez ne
peut pas dire d'aidé tout comme seuls
les vacances se terminer la crise est
aiguë nom peut pas et bien que la cote
de la majorité soit le de la gauche en
baisse le 9 maintenant voilà je veux
savoir demain mercredi va se tenir le
sommet de la gauche le grand logis je
vois ça va d'après vous mon caporal chef
quels seront les attitudes de chacun des
participants eh bien écoutez je doute
pendant que monsieur mitterrand sorte de
sa réserve
je doute que monsieur marchait sorte de
son intransigeance et je doute que
monsieur fabre sorte de sa pharmacie
plus que je pense que les deux autres
n'auront pas l'idée de le faire venir
oui ils vont oublier de la vitesse qu'on
fait
vous savez que mon adjudant fort qu'est
ce que vous pensez que monsieur marché
va aller à ce sommet avec un couteau sur
la table comme il a il a écouté j'ai
plutôt le chantent ils n'ont comme
monsieur marc frey va venir avec son
sécateur d'avant pour vous savez ce
petit appareil qui sert à raccourcir les
roses ah bon c'est plutôt aussi va
plutôt en dessous
le sous-préfet quelle sera votre
attitude
quelle est votre attitude à l'égard des
déclarations fracassantes de gens aux
vaccins en face à valframbert s'avère ça
permet de jj
oui à la veille d'elle de la signature
du manifeste de la majorité il a dit des
choses énormes savoir écouter je pense
que le prochain conseil des ministres
consacrera jean-jacques servan-schreiber
premier cosmonaute perpétuelle franchet
ça consiste en quoi c'est à dire écoutez
nous allons l'envoyer sur orbite et je
pense que c'est la seule façon pour
l'empêcher de débloquer ah oui bien
maintenant je prends finir mon général
je voudrais savoir ce que vous pensez de
l'étalement des vacances je suis pour
l'étalement sous toutes les formes plus
pour l'étalement vous dire je londres
big ben les gens oui la majorité me suis
voyez comme le motion j'étais allé aux
municipales vont enfin quand on vient de
s'étaler on peut quand même se ramasser
par la suite donc c'est vrai nous
comptons nous ramasser aussi aux
législatives oui bah c'est pas c'est pas
mal barré
pensez maintenant on pourra peut-être
élever un peu le débat si vous voulez
bien et je voudrais savoir
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière le
personnage officiel de valérie machin
distincts non non c'est une image qu'on
doit savoir en un mot qui êtes-vous vge
pour de bon s'il vous plaît et je pense
que je suis humble avant tout car comme
le disait si bien montaigne si haut que
l'on souhaite à 6
ce
comme le disait si bien montaigne où que
l'on soit assis ce n'est jamais que sur
son derrière et oui mais aussi chez vous
vous situez aussi des parties donc
séjour à dire et je pense d'ailleurs que
je conduirai la majorité puisque vous le
savez dans quelques temps il y aura un
choix à faire et oui justement je
voulais vous poser la question si vous
en avez prévu pour les procès n'aurait
coûté non alors jacques pierre vous êtes
gentils vous coupez comment les parents
directs jeudi je jouerai pas que les
français imaginent que le président
connaissent les
bons c'est pas en direct voir avec ben
tu peux y aller bazire oui oui je sais
ne soyez pas ce que je voudrais jouer il
faut pas que je change que des questions
je ne connais pas les questions à
l'avancé
non je ne connais que l'airé plomb
connaissent toutes les règles mais
connaît pas alors on reprend là jacques
pierre et puis voilà on va repartir oui
alors dossier le ministre en chef
faudrait savoir
la grande question que tout le monde se
pose sauf moi parce que je serais tu
réellement égal
c'est dans six mois dit si maintenant
les français auront un choix assez bien
j'espère que ce sera un bon choix madame
bon choix manager n'ont jamais su
[Applaudissements]
fait peu non non
[Musique]